dermatologists say that if you just put
sunscreen on every day you will stay
looking younger longer I tried to do
sunscreen every day and I hated it
because I don't like getting oilless
stuff on my hands and be like ah I'll
just do it later which became never it
wasn't until I figured out that
chapstick actually has SPF in it it's
gonna look weird as you can
actually just put it wherever you like
want to cover and it's clear and then
you don't have to get on your hands
I actually use this all the time now and
what's cool is that this stuff sticks
way longer than any kind of sunscreen
does I love this thing it is weird as
but I really like it so maybe it'll
work for you